e
e e
I like to to
uh I'd like toh call our
uh meeting to order Capital project
overview um and start with um the
minutes
approve motion made and seconded to
approve the minutes all those in favor
signify by saying I
I um new
one one
exstension um under new business uh
Canon Mountain advisory commission uh
item number
2410 Department natural and cultural
resources please good morning
commissioner nice to have you here with
us good morning everybody Sarah Stewart
commissioner of the Department of
Natural and cultural resources and with
me is Jace worth who is newly employed
with the state of New Hampshire he moved
here from Colorado
um to run frankone Notch State Park
which of course includes Canon
Mountain
welcome there uh very much excited to uh
be here today with you just uh brief
about me been in the ski business for
going on uh 15 years now um I have uh
sort of Built My Career on transforming
independent ski areas um certainly
Capital Improvements have been a big
part of that managed over 50 million in
capital Improvement projects in my
career thus far and uh before you today
our our tranch of projects that the uh
CAC uh approved in mid January uh mid
June excuse
me thank you um and it's a pleasure to
have you with us uh where in Colorado
what facilities did you work with if I
could just ask sure most uh most
recently I served as a a general manager
of grany ranch which is an independent
Resort similar in size and scope to
Canon Mountain frankone not State Park
it's about 20 miles Northwest of Winter
Park Resort in Grant County thank
you um if you would um present the
item sure uh so before you there are um
sort of three major tranches of capital
plan improvements first of which is uh
the approval and the recommendation of
infrastructure improvements asphalt
shingle roof repairs to our primary skia
Services lodges um in the amount of
190,000 secondly would be the some lift
maintenance repair items including uh B
wi bearing to our main detach lift a
Communications line um upgrade and then
um a gearbox rebuild to our Eagle Cliff
fix grip triple lift at the base area
and then lastly we have a uh Mainline
replacement covers uh a couple hundred
meters um from our snow making Pump
House all the way to essentially what is
the base of our skur services right near
our um Eagle Cliff notchview Lodge area
this is to address some of the corrosion
and pinhole issues that we have along
that section of the line it'd be
important to note that that entire
project right now is estimated to be
around 456,000 um what was approved by
the Canam advisory Commission in June
was the amount of
226,000
and that's because uh we just recently
received approval through the land
waterer conservation fund grant program
so Federal Monies to cover half of that
cost um we received approval on that
Grant last week um so half that project
would be uh requested um here in thank
you um questions
do we have a
motion motion's been moved second and
seconded um in favor of item
24010 uh if you're in favor of that
motion signify by saying I I opposed
motion carries
unanimously uh before before you leave
commissioner could you give give us an
update of where we are with the uh with
the Tramway
itself absolutely um
so about four years ago I brought up the
tram to the capital budget um committee
um sort of waving my hands and saying
we're approaching the end of its life um
which is about 40 plus years and this
would be a request for a third iteration
of the tram um we worked closely with
legislators um and
we gleaned information from vendors to
come up with an estimation of what the
price would be that was about 2 years
ago um and we successfully were uh
approved for $18
million um we thought at that time that
the the whole tram package would cost
about $25 million um and we could make
up the the difference with Park funds
Etc um the reality is when we went out
to bid it the bid came back at 33
million um and so we're working with um
with our colleagues at Das DPW we've
talked commissioner Arling house to keep
him up to speed and right now what we're
doing is stepping back and um and and
trying to create opportunity to break up
the the bid so with the hope that we can
um create a validation on the concrete
polls uh that are up the the Tramway to
reduce the price if those concrete poles
are safe and have a long life ahead of
them that would allow for a new bid that
would dramatically reduce the price um
and so uh we're taking on that next sort
of chapter of breaking apart the bid I'm
going to ask um director Brian Wilson if
there's anything else I need to add to
that
summary I would our Capital request for
the
next it is priority for our next Capital
request
um it really is a state decision uh the
tram has become an iconic uh tourist
attraction of course we want it
selfishly for the revenue for state
parks which is operationally self-funded
uh it's a big big piece of Revenue that
said you know we had people come and
testify as far away as Hampton Beach to
say you know when you invested in the
seashell at the beach it really did a
big uh Improvement to the local economy
if you invest in this you know we would
applaud you because uh because it's
another opportunity to make a big
economic impact in another region of the
state we work closely with the White
Mountain attractions up there and
lodging and restaurants who want to see
this happen um and so we're really
turning to the legislative process to
help us figure out the best financial
path forward thank you commissioner any
further questions for the
commissioner mad if I could get you to
stay just for minutes I have a couple
questions for you after thank you all
right we will move to our um to our next
item uh Harbor's uh dredge and Pier
maintenance fund uh item
24008 good morning miles Greenway acting
Port director so I have two items uh 008
and
009 uh 008 so this is to approve the
expenditure of $50,000 from the harbor
dredging and peer maintenance fund for
the necessary emergency repairs uh at
the division's facilities uh repairs are
critical for ensuring the safety of
vessels Personnel uh maintaining
essential docking and Fuel Services for
emergency
responders thank you uh questions of the
committee on item
008 rep yeah I just have one uh uh
underneath your explanation uh it does
say the division shall report to the
committee in writing the specifics of
the expenditures as they are made or as
otherwise directed by the committee and
I just want to make sure the committee
is okay with that that we have how will
we normally get this we will normally
get this after the expenditure at our
following meeting Mr Shay if I might
crochet LBA um you'll see in your packet
today 007 is an informational item from
P that's the report that they do after
they expend this emergency money so it
follows up um about once a year they do
an itemized report as to how that money
was spent and again this 50,000 was
something that the committee's allowed
for a number of years now because of the
um infrequency of meeting and the
repairs that might come particularly
during wintertime when damage comes from
snow and rain so the the port has the
ability to address those um
thank you any further
questions um move to uh uh approve capap
24008 moved in seconded if you're in
favor of the motion to approve item 008
piece Development Authority division of
ports and harbor is signified by saying
I I any opposed motion carries unanimous
um miles would you continue at item
number nine please yes so 24 tax
009 uh this is to approve the
expenditure of $50,000 from the harbor
drudging and Pier maintenance fund uh to
partially support the US Car US Army
Core of Engineers Hampton Harbor it's a
107 uh feasibility dredging study uh the
division previously secured approval
through the arpa funds to cover the
state's portion of the study uh it was
originally estimated at
$516,500 increased to approximately
5,000
$5,050 so we are
$34,000 uh uh gapped so this is to uh
have up to $50,000 so we can make up
that uh Gap thank you
questions second uh seeing no questions
motion's been made and seconded if
you're in favor of item number 009 peace
Development Authority division of ports
and harbor signified by saying I I if if
you're oppose nay motion carries
unanimous thank you sir thank you we
have some informational items um that
are listed as item five six and
seven um
and looks like number 11 Department of
Revenue Administration which is quite a
report I'm hoping everyone will get a
chance to go through that is other than
setting the date of our next meeting is
there something more we should be I just
wanted to go over the information items
pretty quickly with you um we do have
representative here from the fishing
game department if there's any Hatchery
questions and we do have Dr
representation here if there's any
questions related to the rims
informational item so the fishing game
item in the capital budget there was a
note related to a um the um
appropriation for some of the Hatchery
money for the Powder Mill that said that
they needed to do the Powder Mill
project first and then any balance
remaining could be used Statewide for
Hatchery purposes this memo is um the
Department's way of showing the
committee that you they've done what was
asked of them and so it breaks out what
they think they would need for Powder
Mill and then what they plan on using
the rest of the funds for they're still
in the process of um getting bids and
and getting the exact cost related to
that um but it is to give the committee
um a sense of what they you know that
they did meet the requirement that was
provided to them um I do have some
additional information I can hand out to
the committee related to the hatchery in
terms of some of the costs and I'll do
that when I'm done speaking but if you
do want to hear from them they are
here um the second item is the
administrative Services quarterly report
the only notation there is that um the
community college system reports
information on the capital budget
appropriation that they have in this
quarterly report however there's a note
in the capital budget that requires a a
more detailed in information there was
some confusion they thought they were
meeting the requirements
um through this report after having a
discussion with members of the community
college system they're going to provide
a more detailed report for your next
meeting but just wanted to make sure
that they the committee understood that
they thought they were meeting the
requirement that's why you hadn't seen
something more detailed um we just
discussed the P's one real quickly and
then the last item is the Department of
Revenue item and it's really the second
side of that is is what's important to
this committee which was the um funding
mechanism for the Department's computer
system rims and how they um get revenue
from that to pay for their bonds so I
just it's a high view if you want to
detail questions like I said there are
people here from Dr as well as fishing
game does the committee wish toh hear
from U these individuals these
departments I I appreciate you taking
the time to be here and I'd had several
conversations with the fishing game uh
about the situation was happening so I I
appreciate all of that I especially
appreciate all the time and effort that
was put into this report by the
Department of Revenue thank
you um seeing no further questions then
I would like to float November 12th uh
900 a.m. is our next meeting for uh for
this committee and uh provide you some
time to check your schedules and
uh if you could get back to myself for
Mr Shay on
that we'll know the uh we'll know the
landscape by then
so all
right is there any other uh business to
come before the committee before we
close accept a motion motion to close
the meeting I motion's been made and
accepted if you're in favor of ending
our meeting please signify by saying I I
thank you all for attending uh next
meeting will be at 9:30